if you want to get married you should
get married and if you want to get
divorced if you're already married you
should be allowed to get divorced
without having to prove that your spouse
committed some kind of fault I know that
this sounds really crazy apparently to
some right Wingers who want to do away
with so-called no fault divorce and this
all stemmed because of Stephen Crowder
bemoaning the fact that his wife she can
just choose to get divorced in the state
of Texas this was not
my choice my then wife decided that she
didn't want to be married anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted but if you call
yourself a small government individual
if you call yourself a Libertarian if
you call yourself for lead freedom and
liberty and all of those things
why would you want to restrict
individuals saying hey you know what I
don't want to be married anymore it is
yet another attempt from Republicans to
control women no fault divorce obviously
should remain legal